[Music]
what's going on guys
Wonder Woman it's hitting theaters
really soon and the buzz is pretty good
this is just the latest film in the DC
extended universe movies that are
jam-packed with stars but they weren't
always larger-than-life heroes and
villains so please join us as we journey
back in time let's start with Wonder
Woman herself gal gadot before she was
playing the famous amazon and fighting
to save the world she was fighting for
the universe Miss Universe that's right
here she is competing in the 2004 Miss
Universe pageant as Miss Israel Israel
19 year old rose Regios beat her
independence she defends much giving her
freedom off and almost making her homes
efficacy watch her talents include
flying an invisible jet kicking butt oh
and saving the DCE you Chris Pine enters
the DC EU starring opposite gal gadot as
Steve Trevor but here he is on CSI Miami
looking like the lead singer of an early
2000s emo band you know started off
completely sensual positions
places and then things changed I found
the ultimate thrill looking into
someone's eyes as they died nice lip
ring pine Ben Affleck's Batman teamed up
with Wonder Woman and Batman V Superman
but before he donned the cape and the
cow he was trying to set up his TV mom
with a boyfriend in this weird
after-school special called the perfect
guy
hurry back I just picked it up you're
married yes for the deal what's the big
deal what's the big deal mother is my
love letters a nasty what's the big deal
I didn't read anything what's going on
when this was made Ben Affleck had to
place an ad in a newspaper to find a guy
for his mom I would say that's creepy
but I don't know if I'm quite the person
to judge creepy activities with one's
mom before he was Aquaman ruler of the
oceans Jason Momoa was watching another
aquatic realm the bay he was watching
the bay he was on Baywatch let's
remember that so what I get a van a van
please I'm a single guy first time in
Hawaii sunshine blue skies come on help
me out here
[Music]
that was porno music right prior to
becoming suicide squads Deadshot we all
know that Will Smith used to kick it in
a town called bel-air but you may not
remember this guest star on Fresh Prince
but folks before we go too far I've got
something to tell you
excuse me but I've got something to tell
you first thank you for ruining my life
especially what you do
everybody's always blaming me for
everything
some things never change you may know
Russell Crowe as jor-el father of
Superman but for that he cut his teeth
as a star of a cheesy industrial video
about workman's comp you should be back
at work by the Omni soon ready for light
duties why duties what the hell does
that mean
are you not fairly compensated for the
amount of work you have to miss relative
to your job related injuries yeah
doesn't it seem ring to it before we
knew margot robbie is daddy's little
monster you could have seen her on an
aussie show called the elephant princess
I don't wish to us
I would like to confess that that mom
ouch whoa next-level fight choreography
all I was missing with the baseball bat
Harley Quinn today Jared Leto is most
known for his let's say controversial
and very shirtless tatted up depiction
of the Joker but Jared's shirtless
acting goes way back to his very first
IMDB credit as Dexter on the short-lived
TGIF sitcom camp Wilder it also stars
Hilary Swank
here's Jared pining for the future all
right this is hard being a new guy I
wish that was a tough part you know
sometimes I wish I wish I could just be
40 you know with a wife a kid a dog and
a Dairy Queen franchise not us to worry
about stupid things pretty sure Jared is
still searching for all those things by
the way fun fact
there's three Oscars between those two
people not bad in the DC EU you know him
as General Zod but did you know that
Michael Shannon was in Groundhog Day
excuse me mr. Conners hey Fred how was
the wedding well I just wanted to thank
you for making Debbie go through with it
everything all I did was fan the flame a
professional camera
Michael Shannon was so fresh-faced and
innocent back then who knew he'd grow up
to be our favorite super-intense
unblinking suppressing a quiet rage
character actor WrestleMania we need to
talk about Ezra Miller who is starring
as the flash and justice Lee when he was
just a kid though he had a small role as
a bully and something called cakey the
cake from outer space we're still not
sure what this is but we found it on
YouTube and Ezra Miller is definitely in
it you're invited to a party Oh food
sorry dump can IH twice fezzes normal so
ye hole
[Laughter]
music if you have any information to
help us discern what exactly keiki the
cake from outer space is please leave it
in the comment section below
way before taking on the role of Lex
Luthor Jesse Eisenberg had his very
first role on the TV show
get real where he had to really stretch
his range by playing an awkward teenager
here he is trying to push the boundaries
of awkward by giving a behind-the-scenes
tour to a host that seems set on asking
the lamest possible questions for doing
a scene for seven hours eating cucumber
really I can't wait to get home and eat
some work you comfortable if you like
Forrest Gump with the shrimp I could
like get every kind of food in cereal
but are they real sorry oh this food is
really occasionally you know the only
thing that cliff needed for jesse
eisenberg to put the Jolly Rancher in
that guy's mouth today Amy Adams aka
Lois Lane is a five-time oscar-nominated
actress who effortlessly switches from
prestige pictures to blockbusters but
back in the year 2000 she was starring
in a weird 1960s throwback called psycho
beach party and playing a whole
different type of character this is a
manhunt let's set our trap
later in the same movie she also gets
her bikini ripped off by Xander from
Buffy you can take back your tacky old
ten cent pin and help you with that
hands off of me unit Laurence Fishburne
plays Perry White in the DC EU and he's
famous for playing serious badasses but
back in the late 80s he played the
opposite of a badass cowboy Curtis on
pee-wee's Playhouse here he is with
peewee practising for a date what did
you say at your date's tool I had a
wonderful time miss Yvonne and thank you
for inviting ya welcome hi another
nipple time Joe can I see you again
sometime
[Music]
please we had such a lovely time what
good spyler
a year later he left pee-wee's Playhouse
for the hood that's right boys in the
hood where he played furious styles oh
oh you bad man that guy's got range well
that was a good time so which of those
Clips was your favorite also were there
any deep cuts from people's IMDb's that
we left out let us know in the comments
below we want to know I want to thank
you for watching screen junkies I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
[Music]